all eyes were on the result of a secret
ballot that could sway the course of
history
by backing Teresa may her MPs are
probably defining brexit and the shape
it will take
but a no-confidence vote from a hundred
and seventeen MPs amplifies the division
within her party which for many remains
unresolved
what does treasom a need to do now to
win back your confidence
Teresa may has lost confidence and
political authority when Prime
Minister's get to the point of setting
an end date for their term in office
their political authority evaporates so
she has not only seen a vote of 117
members the overwhelming majority of the
non-payroll vote against her she is also
even to get the vote she got had to give
away that very important part of her
political capital I'm a Democrat so I'll
respect the decision but I will still if
trees are made it still brings this deal
back to Parliament I will still vote it
down
what concessions could she get to change
your mind on that well she needs to go
back to the drawing board she's never
ever you know put our country first in
these negotiations other break searchers
disagree the Prime Minister's lifeline
came from support of people like Michael
Gove the man she once told to go away
and learn about loyalty is now the most
significant advocate of her withdrawal
deal so if she wins you're still stuck
with the daily car get through
Parliament he was right about the first
bit the second remains up in the air
Parliament like the country remains
divided and in some cases very angry
the Prime Minister now needs more
positive Christmas spirit from her party
and the EU having one missus make and
remain leader unchallenged for 12 months
on Thursday she heads to Brussels for
the European Council summit and she
needs concessions to get their
withdrawal agreement through the House
of Commons she's promised Parliament
will get a vote before January the 21st
but she could still lose it and labour
could then challenge the government with
a vote of no-confidence to try to force
a general election I hope my colleagues
will take a careful look about who's
leading us what the choices are and what
the alternative is if they don't support
it I mean quite frankly it would be an
ironic if it was the brexit ears that
stopped us leaving the European Union
but many feel the Prime Minister's
festive mission is still hanging by a
thread
she must change her direction she has
not come up with a plan B she needs to
get her deal back into Parliament we
need to have that vote but she'll lose
we all know that and then she has to
tell us what her plan B is going to be I
think there is she has only one route
out of this and she should grasp it and
own it which is to take her deal back to
the British people have that people vote
that the people have the final say this
failed coup by the brexit wing of the
party has weakened their position now
that she can't be challenged for a year
the Prime Minister has more freedom she
could for example say to her rebels that
if they don't back her deal then she
might have to lean towards a softer
brexit in order to win support from
opposition MPs but nothing from the last
24 hours has changed the deal that would
have been rejected this week by the MPs
who fill these benches Mrs May has
sacrificed standing in the next election
in order to survive she's proved
resilient but it will take a will of
iron to break the deadlock
Jason Farrell Sky News